hey guys do you know how to hide your
shoelaces the right way because you know
how bad it looks when it creeps out and
you only notice it after a few minutes
if you don't know how to hide them let
me show you
[Music]
all right now i'm not going to waste
your time i'm jumping right into this
now normally when people want to hide
their shoelaces they just put their
shoelaces all the way to the front
inside the shoes like this and then they
put it on but of course this is so
uncomfortable so i don't know why people
do this there are better ways to do it
let's start with number one
[Music]
all right guys now the first thing that
you need to do is always put your
shoelaces outside in not inside out
because you don't want to see this part
of the laces over your shoes so outside
in then tied normally
and tuck it in to one side preferably to
the inside of your feet where you have
more space
so it won't be that uncomfortable this
way it will stay tight and look neat
but honestly this is not my preferred
method so let's move on to number two
[Music]
number two is actually very easy and
once you do this
it's a lot easier to put your shoes on
every time
what you want to do is take your laces
and put them underneath the insole of
your shoes this is more comfortable and
you will never have to worry about
always making the effort to tuck them in
get elastic shoelaces and just replace
them with the old ones this is easy all
you got to do is just adjust them once
keep it there with a lace anchor and
then that's it perfect for ever almost
it'll be more like a slip-on you can get
it from a few places but i'll add the
links for you in the video description
down below
just a bonus tip get a shoehorn believe
me when i say this this is one of those
kind of things that you only appreciate
once you get it and once you use it and
you see it for yourself
if you use a shoe horn you won't damage
your own shoes and also it's going to
save you so much time because it's so
much faster to put on your shoes now if
you want any more tips on styling
grooming fitness or life itself check
out one of these videos here and i'll
see you there
before you go remember this
life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys